as Diane just introduced what Khan
Academy is most known for is this
library of videos that I started
producing almost five six years ago now
so before I go any further let me just
show you all a little bit of a of a mix
of what the videos actually look like
and then we can go a little deeper from
there so the hypotenuse is now going to
be five this animals fossils are only
found in this area of South America a
nice clean band here and this part of
Africa we could integrate over the
surface and the notation usually is a
capital Sigma National Assembly they
create the Committee of Public Safety
which sounds like a very nice committee
notice this is an aldehyde and it's an
alcohol start differentiating into
effector and memory cells a galaxy hey
there's another galaxy oh look there's
another galaxy and for dollars is there
thirty million plus the twenty million
dollars from the American manufacturer
if this does not blow your mind then you
have no emotion
[Applause]
so I you know the videos there's there's
not 2200 of them that's kind of what I
want to do until you know I get hit by a
bus or what hopefully won't be for a
while but I we're doing a lot more than
that I mean that the videos are reaching
actually now on the order of about two
million unique users a month we've had
almost 45 million video views they're
being watched two to three hundred
thousand times a day but before I go any
deeper you know I actually just gave a
talk at ed down in Long Beach a couple
of weeks ago and I don't want this to be
a repetition of this of that talk I want
this to kind of be a part too but before
I go any further I want to get a sense
just so I know how much background and
depth I need to give how many of y'all
have seen that talk okay good good and
how many of you all have been to the
site because I want to know how much the
background okay very good very good so
what I want to focus on today is kind of
going a little bit deeper I will give a
background about what we're doing
beyond the video portion now that it
isn't just me that we are actually are
kind of a team now where we're at six
people and then it it and then address
some of the questions that I think have
have surfaced as if we've gotten a
little bit more popular and we've
started to enter into domains that
frankly I never thought we would enter
especially into the classroom itself but
before I do that I want to give you all
a little bit of a thought experiment
imagine if if we're in a juggling class
and I'm your I'm your juggling
instructor and this week we are going to
learn to juggle oranges and so I give
you all your orange juggling kits I give
you all each for oranges and I give you
all a little lecture on juggling oranges
and I say practice and in a week I will
assess your orange juggling ability and
so you practice and a week later I come
back with my clipboard and I say juggle
and so you you tried the best you can to
juggle and you know different three
oranges four oranges all the rest and I
say oh you know can't juggle four
oranges at all three oranges barely can
keep the ball the oranges in the air for
for more than a few seconds you are 70%
orange juggler you are ad orange juggler
and I place that that label on your
forehead I put in your
in your permanent record of making it
all but impossible for you to go to an
elite juggling school and despite those
deficiencies that you clearly have in
your abilities
I there's a state-mandated jug juggling
a curriculum that we have to follow and
there's a calendar that specifies this
how we have to move forward we have this
kind of assembly line and so I say well
give me back the oranges the next lesson
here are some knives and as crazy as
that might appear to be that's exactly
what's happening in our classrooms right
now it might not be as physically
dangerous but but it is just as mentally
dangerous
we have students they take an exam they
get 10 percent wrong 20 percent wrong 30
percent wrong you can even fail an exam
and regardless of the fact that we've
identified those deficiencies we know
that the student doesn't know those
concepts we have to move on to the next
concept we have this assembly line that
the only thing we're using the test for
is to put labels on people's foreheads
to separate them to track them but then
when we know there's weaknesses we push
them forward and we're pretty much
ensuring that at some future point
they're going to fail we're pretty much
ensuring that motivated kids even if
they have awesome teachers at some point
those gaps are going to come back and
they're not going to be able to perform
once they get to some more advanced
mathematics so now that that we've we've
gotten a funding you know and just so
you know a little bit of the story how
all of this happened I was literally
making videos in my in my closet for for
about five years and then about a year
ago Google brought me over to their
campus and you know I thought it was
just like you know a lot of the Google
engineers that they have parents they
were using these videos for their
children and all of that but they
brought me into a conference room and
they said Sal what would you do at two
million dollars and
and I said is this an education context
or just as a broader question is this a
they're very different answers but uh so
that happened and then a little bit
later and this is actually I mean this
is like last year I was still in the
closet the the I get a call from from
Larry Cohen who's Bill Gates his chief
of staff and and and says I don't know
if you realize this but but Bill Gates
likes your videos he watches them he
uses with his kids and II would like to
support you do you have some time to
meet him in the near future and I said I
think I can move around my calendar a
little bit I think I can push back a few
of the video recordings here there but
but you fast-forward to October of this
year we got funding from the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation we got the
funding from Google and it essentially
allowed me to come out of the closet and
and and and what we're now trying to do
there is take these videos to their to
their natural conclusion and and address
that juggling mastery problem so what
we're doing if you go to the side it's
all free it's a not-for-profit
not trying to sell anything you can
start it one plus one equals two and
keep and and we'll give you as many
problems as you need and as you get ten
in a row you can keep advancing to more
and more advanced concepts and so the
the paradigm here is don't move on to a
next concept until you the until you
master the one you already know and so
as an organization what we're trying to
do and and it seems like there's already
a little bit but we're getting the
traction here and we'll talk later and
to talk about why we think we're getting
that traction what we're trying to do is
enable anyone anywhere in the world for
free to get one an education but when we
say an education to get an education
that really is a mastery based education
one that really ensures that someone
understands the basics before they move
forward and they can do it all at their
own pace and I want to be clear and this
is actually and this will you know we'll
talk more about this at the second half
of the talk this isn't a new idea it's
actually nothing nothing that Khan
Academy doing is fundamentally new doing
videos
either online or even on TV or whatever
it's not a new idea when that when radio
was first invented when TV was first
invented people thought it was going to
revolutionize education put the best
teachers broadcast them it never
happened even when the internet was
first and it kind of came out they
thought that was going to be the killer
app and on for the Internet when when
the PC was first invented they thought
this was the first time we can give
people self-paced learning but it never
got traction so in the second half of my
talk I'd like to think a little bit
about maybe why we're getting traction
it's a super important question for for
us as an organization because we don't
want to lose whatever that secret sauce
might be the other interesting thing
that's happened and I talk a lot more
about this and in the other TED talk is
and it was actually a big surprise to me
is that our software and video start to
get adopted in the classroom and and I
mentioned the previous talk that it
happened early on even before we got
funding or anything I start getting
letters from teachers who's saying that
they were using just the videos to flip
the education model they were now
assigning the videos for a lecture
they were assigning the videos for
homework and instead of doing a lecture
in the classroom they were actually
doing they were actually allowing their
students to interact with each other's
and doing problems and so they actually
just with that simple technology just
the on-demand video they were actually
able to kind of personalize and and make
the actual classroom experience
interactive and so now with this this
kind of self-paced mastery-based
learning software we were approached by
the Los Altos School District not too
far from here what would you do with the
classroom and we said well we would let
every student work at their own pace and
the teachers role would be to have a
dashboard they would have all of the
data and only intervene on the students
that are stuck and so you can do a very
focused intervention and be armed with
the right data to do it and or even
better get a student who's already
proficient in that to intervene for that
on that student and you get all of the
benefits of learning something even
deeper when you yourself are the teacher
so they decided to do it and so in Los
Altos we have two fifth grade classes
and two seventh grade classes and
they're using this as their their core
curriculum and and what I want to
emphasize here and it's not always made
clear is when Pete when you talked when
I talked about this to people a lot of
people this is awesome
you know a self-paced learning mastery
based differentiated instruction but
there is a crowd that starts to get a
little suspicious they start saying well
this sounds like you're you know this
you're automating things but it sounds
like it's very robotic it sounds like
you know kids in front of a in front of
a computer just you know doing exercises
all day listening to videos not
interacting with each other it sounds
like you're marginalizing the teacher it
sounds like you're distilling the
teacher that you're making them kind of
just just do what what the what the
computers can't and what I want to
emphasize here is this the exact
opposite what we're seeing in those
classrooms in Los Altos is we're seeing
every moment of that teachers time is
spent interacting with with her students
being a mentor these students are
getting one-on-one with the teacher
multiple times a week when we were when
I was in school I was lucky to get that
you know even a few times and even in
your in your whole career multiple times
a week they aren't they aren't doing
this at the expense of project-based
learning or investigations what this is
allowing that you should do it liberates
the classroom so now that they can do
more of the project-based learning they
can do more of the investigations these
classrooms in Los Altos there is more of
that creative activity more of this
interaction more of this of this
experimenting with the world than you
would see in any other classroom so for
the first time because we have this
technology it's not an either/or
proposition you have these kind of camps
of mathematical instruction do you do
kind of the traditional do a lot of
problems lecture and see a lot of
traditional problems or do you do the
project-based learning where you
investigate things and our answer is now
we can we can do both and even better
even on the instruction itself there's
these debates between old math and new
math how do you do it and the value when
you have on-demand video you can do both
you can actually expose the students to
every possible way that there is to
learn mathematics and in the same
classrooms you have one kid doing 3rd
grade math and you have one kid doing
algebra and that's great that the
student doing the 3rd grade math needs
to be doing the 3rd grade math he or she
needs to fill out those gaps and the
student who's doing the algebra should
allow should be able to run forward and
do the algebra and then some people tell
what this is bad you know already the
smart kids have the advantage of the
slow kids you know they already have
every disadvantage and now you're making
the spread even wider but what they
don't realize is in these same
classes it's becoming impossible to
figure out over a longer term who those
smart kids are and who the slower kids
are because even though one kid is
working on third-grade math for a little
while
once he or she is getting those guys so
we see it over and over again they're
able to race ahead and then three weeks
later they've passed up the kid who's in
algebra so all of these kind of labels
start to disappear the other the other
thing that you know we're kind of
thinking about it as we grow our
organization and we really want to make
sure we have a good hold on it is why is
it working why is it resonating you know
these ideas have existed forever
on-demand video self-paced learning and
you know the first the real data points
we've been getting obviously if it had
the user growth we've had the traction
Bill Gates uses it but but but for me
personally the real the real data points
has just been the the user testimonies
the letters that we get and actually you
know the first feedback has turned into
a little bit of a one-liner
was from my cousins who you know their
very first feedback when I put 20 or 30
videos up for them they said that they
preferred me on youtube than in person
but uh but we just keep getting them and
I think there's you know there's a
common theme here and I'll just I'll
just read a couple real quick but you
know there's one my eldest kid is
dancing around in my room here because
she is so excited that she finally saw
it found someone that teaches like this
and you know I feel uncomfortable I
don't like doing the self praise I mean
you know I don't but but but what's cool
here what's cool here is that this this
girl she wasn't just happy when she
learned something when she was actually
able to connect with the material it
wasn't like oh I'm gonna get an a on the
exam she felt the visceral desire to
dance
this and and there's all sorts you know
this is a letter and this takes me back
to my my college days when when I didn't
have a girlfriend I don't know if these
boys at Bellarmine can relate to this
comment but but so this is a comment
from a college student there's always so
much else that a student has on their
mind
what is the pretty girl looking like
today what was the professor like when
they were a student should I talk to the
pretty girl after class
well I include last weekend's event in a
book about my life that the slightest
drifting of focus quickly turns into a
fruitless two hours spent daydreaming or
unconscious please continue what you are
doing and it was actually a much letter
a much longer letter than have to redact
it wasn't appropriate for this for this
miss audience it was uh and then this is
one I got I got two days ago I've taken
calculus one three times the first time
I didn't pass the class the second time
I had to drop the class my girlfriend's
mom told me about the site she heard
about at a conference I checked it out I
began supplementing preceding and
sometimes even replacing my lectures
with your videos and I received an 84%
on my first midterm she this is the
third time he's taking it I almost cried
I was so happy
and you know I'd and when I when I first
try 84 that's a good score why is he
crying especially because the class
average was a 47%
[Applause]
now the second midterm is coming up I
feel confident enough to say that I will
most likely get an A in the class since
my major depends on me passing the class
I want to thank you for helping me save
my college career so it's pretty you
know a mind mind mind blowing stuff and
I think I think I think you can imagine
why I quit my day job as a hedge fund
manager what wasn't wasn't quite as much
psychic reward but I think the takeaway
here is is that and this is the learning
that we have this thing that we never
want to forget as an organization is
that people come to the Khan Academy
wanting to just fill in the gap they
have an exam they want to pass an exam
but once they actually experience what
it's like to learn it doesn't matter who
they are it could be the students who's
about to drop out once they actually
experience it for the first time of life
they get addicted it's a natural hide
it's it's something that we innately all
humans want to have and that's something
as an organization we don't want to ever
forget that if we can form these human
bonds using technology that's what's
actually going to allow us to succeed
and so I want to leave you with one
quick a little story from from one of
the Los Altos classrooms last week that
kind of hits hits the point home there
was a reporter from NBC doing a story on
what we're doing in that classroom and
there's a little fifth grader and she's
doing trigonometry and actually all of
the boys are very envious um because she
has the most badges and points and all
of that other's things and the reporter
sits down next to her and says do you
think this is 5th grade math and then
the little girl has a mischievous smile
and she looks at the reporter she goes
no I think it's sixth grade thank you
[Applause]